well I'm not fond of cats I've never
been fond of cats and never wanted a cat
but I once was ill-advised enough to
bribe one of my children to feel more
cheerful about coming back to Britain
from America where we were living at the
time by saying well of course if we go
back to Britain you can have a cat and I
think that I'd rather hope that she
would forget about it
I certainly had forgotten about it but
as soon as we back in Britain there she
was where's my cat I want my cat so we
had this card she liked it I didn't like
it it was nice to her it was not nice to
me
my partner's a gardener and likes birds
so he obviously hated the cat and the
Diary of a killer cat is an urban myth
and I'm just going to read you the first
few pages of it Monday okay okay so hang
me I killed the bird for pity's sake I'm
a cat it's practically my job to go
creeping around the garden after sweet
little eensy-weensy birdy pies that can
hardly fly from one hedge to another so
what am I supposed to do when one of the
poor feathery little flutter balls just
about throws itself into my mouth I mean
it practically landed on my paws it
could have hurt me okay okay so he
biffed it is that any reason for Ellie
to cry am i first so hard I always drown
and squeeze me so hard I almost choked
oh she says sniffles and red eyes and
piles of wet tissues Oh Tuffy how could
you do that how could I do that I'm a
cat how did I know there was gonna be
such a giant great fuss with Ellie's
mother rushing off to fetch sheets of
old newspaper and Ellie's father filling
a bucket with soapy water okay okay so
maybe I shouldn't have dragged it in and
left it on the carpet and maybe this
stains won't come out ever so hang me
Tuesday
I quite enjoyed the little funeral I
don't think they really wanted me to
come but after all it's just as much my
garden as theirs
in fact I spend a whole lot more time in
it than they do I'm the only one in the
family who uses it properly not that
they're grateful you ought to hear them
that cat is ruining my flowerbeds there
are hardly any of the petunias left I'd
barely planted the loopy Leah's before
it was lying on top of them squashing
them flat
I do wish it wouldn't dig holes Indian
enemies Mon Mon Mon Mon I don't know why
they bother to keep a cat
since the will they ever seem to do is
complain all except Ellie she was too
busy being Saki about the bird she put
it in a box and packed it round with
cotton wool and dug a little hole and
then we all stood round it while she
said a few words wishing the bird luck
in heaven go away Ali's father hissed at
me I find that man quite rude but I just
flicked my tail at him gave him the
blink who does he think he is if I want
to watch a little birdies funeral I'll
watch it after all I've known the bird
longer than any of them have I knew it
when it was alive
you